ich teste neueröffnung in der letzten
zeit haben irgendwie super viele neue
restaurants hier in meiner heimatstadt
köln aufgemacht und ich dachte mir ich
teste die un haben sie mir allesamt
aufgespart für dieses video heute wir
haben einen laden der uni gemacht wir
haben ein philips der export und wir
haben ein schönes italienisches
restaurant was braucht man mehr möglich
zu sein ich persönlich weiß es nicht und
wir fangen an mit der ersten neu
eröffnen
[Musik]
erster laden den habe ich bei freddy
sturm waffel im video gesehen reis ecke
gibt es ohne g36 sehr intuitiv der name
weil es sind diese dreiecke quasi so
sushi dreiecke könnte man das nennen
aber freue mich sehr darauf ich habe es
schon mal gegessen in düsseldorf in
little tokyo da ist es schön auch sehr
gut aber hier gibt es auf jeden fall
eine riesige vielfalt und wir gucken mal
passieren können
[Musik]
wir haben ordentlich zugeschlagen das
ist auf jeden fall ein sehr
sympathischer besitzer gewesen und ich
glaube ich starte scharfer thunfisch
morgens mit bauchschmerzen auf braucht
erstmal schaffen wir nicht geladen war
super clean innen drin einfach nur die
aussage mit den verschiedenen uni die
rieder aber auch wirklich eine breite
auswahl keine sitzplätze kann nichts
deshalb sind wir jetzt gerade auch
draußen aber war schon mal sehr sehr
cool oder diesem wetter es ist ja auch
kein problem du sagst ich bin profi wir
vergessen einfach alle gemeinsam das
video aus düsseldorf wo ihr mich
kollektiv gerettet habe dafür wie ich
das ganze gegessen habe sagt auspacken
ist nicht ganz einfach das auspacken
dass ich ganz einfach ich habe jetzt
aber geschafft außen haben wir dieses
getrocknete knusprigen orie blatt
dazwischen war gerade noch die
verpackung so dass ich das jetzt erst
aufeinander lediglich das hätte ich in
der hand gar nicht planen gar nicht
komplett 3 ja das weil das sieht fertig
heißt es dass glänzt also wie eine
fischhaut aber ich habe durch sehr groß
ist aber auch sagt ihr wisst ist deshalb
werde ich auch gar nicht mehr lange und
wir vielleicht noch einen moment ab
damit ihr hören könnt ob es krankt
angeblich chronisch ist nämlich sogar
es ist super lecker durch sehr sehr
lecker der reis hat so eine super dazu
berichte ich so krebs
also der hat so richtig
thunfisch super schön scharf ist
wirklich lustig außen und das ist sonst
weg der hat so ein bisschen einzug
gehalten in die supermärkte da kriegt
man schon immer mal uni die ricco war
das ein anderer schnack könnt ihr aber
schreiben gibt es das bei euch habt ihr
schon mal gegessen das auf jeden fall
der beste oder das beste
schmeckt crazy lag gerade innen drin
wenn man so bei der füllung ankommen so
beim kern beim herz an kommt schmeckt
super lecker ist ja sehr neutral aber wo
ich dachte echt über das auch übels
feiert das ist wirklich besonders haben
wir kein festhalten japan hat sowieso
kulinarisch viel zu bieten und so was zu
essen unterwegs im auto auf reisen ist
sowas von überlegen gegenüber so eine
butterbrotdose
dotchev inhalt absoluter profi wie man
jetzt auf mittlerweile merke dir dinge
mit links auf und fährt muss sesam
attacke leicht andere die aromen der
junge das ist glaube ich so der
japanische von dort zu sein pina
baghajati sandwich du hast so eine süße
dabei sagt jetzt dem gefällt alles so ja
ich kann mich für viel essen begeistern
aber das ist unter den vielen gut
bewerteten am oberen ende der skala
der reißt er hat eine gemacht so spaß ja
ja ja weil der ist so saftig und
schmeckt dann schmeckt einfach nicht so
wie sushi reis er woanders gewürzt
weniger menschen die der hatte aber auch
so ein touch preis essig und der so
vollmundig superlecker erste
neueröffnung m12 wissen von anderen
nehme ich noch aber das hat man schon
überzeugt
[Musik]
so gestärkt aber nicht gesättigt sind
hierzu auf der weidengasse und hinter
mir befindet sich bang bang american
philipp steak ultra geile sache ich bin
froh dass es einen laden gibt er sich
nur darauf kommt dass zu machen und wie
es schmeckt wären wir gleich gemeinsam
herausfinden raps barbecue waren wir mal
gemeinsam da gibt es auch viele checks
das ist auch sehr gut dementsprechend
bin ich gespannt wie das hier
abschneiden wird aber was rein von der
aufmachung wir sind so allem eric
althoff im raum stehen und so was ich
esse weiß ich schon die hauptkritik und
wir gucken uns das denn machen
[Musik]
wenn ich nur dass hier sehen würden und
ich wüsste nicht wie ich hierhin
gekommen bin und so ich würde nicht
denken dass ich in deutschland bin ich
denke dass in köln bin ich bin in
philadelphia
also das ist ja wirklich ein kunstwerk
also das sieht wirkt nichts daran sieht
nach deutschland aus auch der ganze
laden so meines notebooks oder anderen
eia solange das war jetzt richtig sehr
schön gemacht alles bestens
also eric hat sich spontan entschieden
entschied einzulegen
außerhalb von travels auch schwer das
ist wahr das ist super das ist auch von
innen und von außen mit knoblauch
bestätigen versorgen jetzt ja auch get
your hands für die uns doch es geht auch
anders
sicherlich das schickt nicht schlafen
halter ist das und danach brauchst du so
einen winterschlaf ich glaube das ist so
groß dass so super flüssig scout sich
fast noch nie was in dieser konsistenz
gegessen so dieses gesamte ding als 100
gästen das wollte ich nämlich grad sagen
ich finde krass dass so ein ganz ganz
anderer tag eines philipp stakes
sandwiches jetzt im vergleich zur apps
per video wo wir beim test in amerika
waren voll das ist so premium essen aber
es fühlt sich so an es gibt also diese
bewegung kommt
also wir haben zusammen macht wir haben
das sehr schöne beine hat der agi schon
einen sehr starken eigenen wie flavour
das ist sehr sehr lecker das ding ist
aber ich muss mich sagt für mich das ist
so ich muss mir überlegen kann ich das
heute essen was ich meine ja jetzt ist
so lecker aber es ist schick nicht
schlafen kann sich jetzt verstehen warum
es mir so schwer fällt abzunehmen wenn
wir so was hier drehen alter
ich glaub ich war noch nie so weit weg
von amerika in amerika weil das ist
wirklich so das ist so man steigt und
flieger wenn man hier in den laden geht
es ist einfach komplett authentisch der
besitzer der betreiber hat auch erzählt
er kommt auf sell und wir sind auch
weiterhin das schon mal an zu zittern
aber jetzt den ein oder anderen tipp
geben lassen weshalb bleibt auch darauf
gespannt jetzt nehmen uns erst mal zum
abendessen zum abendessen wird wie
gesagt etwas gemütlich wir setzen uns in
ein italienisches restaurant in das
barilla weil sowie barilla 1 l weniger
und am ende und das gehört zu einer
kette von restaurants die ich sehr gerne
mag immer gutes essen deshalb bin ich
gespannt was hier heute auf der karte
steht drei-gänge-menü freund von mir hat
geburtstag das gute antwort noch mal an
der stelle und vor allen dingen finde
ich auch meisters person nämlich so ein
fußbad drin haben sondern so auch ein
echtes restaurant
[Musik]
so ist erklärte am rande so ein bisschen
was abgeht man hat immer die option
menüs zu bilden mit vorspeise entweder
passt bisher 34 50 bzw 41 5 pro person
finde ich super fair eigentlich weil ihr
werdet sehen kennedy ist das essen ist
immer super vips fast als partner
an jakobs
kann man machen interessante kreationen
werden ist mir so passiert zitiert ist
eine sauce hollandaise und darunter bis
auf einmal hierdurch jakobsmuschel ja
auch wenn man
[Musik]
portionsgröße finde ich auch fair also
vier jakobsmuscheln in einem gang menü
ist ja auch schon öfter so dass man eine
kleinere portion er bekommt was man auf
jeden fall optimistisch oder schafft
vorfreude die hauptspeise ab juni gucken
wir mal wieder ist so steht
herrlichsten aber eric haben wir diesen
gang gefühlig abgefilmt
diesen
aber weil die vorspeise war ja sehr
großzügig dann haben wir hier berater
creme was ihr das innere von der berater
das noch eine tomatensoße und probiert
wir müssen der transparenz
natürlich
also müssen wir nicht schönreden aber
dafür schmeckt aber
da ist auch dieses so zitronat drin
20 männer nicht dran dass lecker ist
aber
gleich kuchen die sicher noch ein nach
einer zeit
es soll aber uns aber trotzdem ich
diesen leckeren kulinarischen tag
versauen oder
nach dem dritten teil davon machen soll
einmal gefühl kommen alle zwei wochen
hier neue denn aus dem boden geschossen
und wir sehen für mich es mal wieder in
scharen